at the end of september end of third
quarter of this year
the economy we think was about nine
percent in terms of activity below where
it was at the end of last year that's
just unprecedented in terms of scale
now we think there will be a further
downturn in the fourth quarter because
of obviously the return of covid not as
big
but there will be a further so i you
know think it's quite likely that the
economy will end this year
probably around 10 or 11 below where it
was in terms of activity end of last
year and that is historically
unprecedented
in terms of the measures you've uh
announced today to try and deal with it
150 billion pounds of quantitative
easing
why do you do that and what's the
intention
well the intention is that we are
putting if you like
liquidity into the economy to enable
people to
to use it businesses to use it
households to use it
so we buy assets that are less
immediately usable and that has two
effects one is that it keeps the cost of
borrowing down
and that stimulates the economy helps us
to meet our inflation target because
the moment we've got inflation well
below our target
and it and as well as doing that it
provides liquidity in the economy that
aids
people who you know want to do spending
and investment and that's what we need
the economy to do we need spending on
investment to get the economy going
again
can you give us an idea of how
destructive
a second imposition of a second wave
let's put it that way
has been to business and consumer
confidence the drivers
of economic activity well it's been true
all through this year that
confidence in the economy of course has
been at a low level
so although we had quite a rapid
recovery of the economy
during the summer although still to a
level well below where it was the
industry
all the surveys of when when people were
asked about their confidence
they did not recover in the same way not
in the same way as we would see
normally in terms of relationships now
i'm not surprised about that because
of course underlying this people are
very nervous apprehensive
about covert itself about you know you
know its incidents the effects of it
and we saw that in terms of people's
stated confidence
yeah well your predecessor used
described code
initially as a sharp a temporary drop of
you what two words might you use when
you're looking at
the long term well i think
the temporary thing is just how long is
covert going to go on for
um the longer term thing is how much
is the effect of covert on the economy
going to do two things one is that it
you know it critically undermines the
capacity of some businesses to survive
it
secondly how much does it change the way
that we all do things you know the way
we work
things we buy the way we buy things uh
all of these things are all these things
we're observing at the moment obviously
the question is how long how are they
going to go for and so are some of them
going to be permanent changes then how
do we adjust the economy because
economies are just all the time
do you think there will be permanent
changes i think there will be some
permanent changes yes i think there will
i
i'd be very surprised if you know we we
came out of covert with with no
permanent changes and it's a matter then
of ensuring that the economy adjusts to
those
uh permanent changes so so we don't get
you know long-term unemployment which is
very damaging history is
you know history has shown us how
damaging that can be
a quick word on brexit you're
forecasting a negative impact
from brexit even with a deal this is the
worst
possible timing isn't it to be doing
this in january in the middle of this
existing crosstalk well i think
first of all i think that we've
conditioned our forecast on the
trade agreement being reached i think
that is the the right thing it's the
government's policy i think it's the
right thing to go through look for a
trade agreement and to
and to get one and of course that
process is still going on
the question you rightly ask then is
what are the adjustment costs because of
course it does involve the uk
leaving the customs union and it does
involve the uk leaving the single market
now there will be adjustment costs for
any trade agreement
uh and we talked to a lot of firms we
our regional agents talked to a lot of
firms
we tried to form a view on preparedness
but let me
let me end with this thought a trade
agreement
and a spirit of good will in which both
sides say
let's make the adjustment to this new
world as easy as we can do and by the
way the uk government has said that it
will by
by delaying the implementation of many
of the the new arrangements
but a spirit of good willingness
achieved will minimize that cost
does it follow that if there's no deal
the hit to gdp will be greater
um well broadly yes it does i mean
obviously the the no deal of course is
is a is it tends to be a sort of very
thin trade agreement actually that's the
way to look at it really and yes of
course obviously the the less trade that
goes on and the more there is a an
adjustment to that
then you know certainly in the short run
certainly the the effects will be larger